hello welcome to hello neighbor
let's play I play this game before but
the full game is out now and now it's
divided into acts how exciting
here we are father they changed us a lot
dude damn that feels like a whole new
game all I remember was I was trying to
infiltrate this man's house for no
reason and for just for some reason he
would get pissed up what is this cut see
you're having coitus Christian Channel
hey man I get it sometimes you got a
lock [ __ ] in the dungeon oh my oh jesus
oh ah hell no the rick and morty fans -
have you kept locked in there here we
are okay so this is our house yes nope
what a great parking you you got there
buddy I love that art style is very 90s
hollow mean I shine I am heading in
closet man they changed so much dude
this is crazy alright let's just go I
can't seem to open it there we go hey
how you doing no no he's drawing stuff
that did it did it did that hey what's
up hey what's that hey what's that nice
legs dude you work oh maybe I can break
the window and sneak him that way
how do I grab stuff that was eat wasn't
it here we go okay you have to hold down
for some reason alright let's break his
window [ __ ] a chow
nailed it catch ow
wow I'm such a good pitcher listen I
just want to know who he keeps in this
sex dungeon I don't think that's too
much to ask
I can peep through the hole as well okay
that's cool oh he's coming he's coming
he's coming he's got back hey
but jumps through their own window it's
doing milk take that what is he doing in
there taking a [ __ ] how am I supposed to
climb back this is worse than getting
over it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm
doing it oh yeah you can't grab me from
here oh [ __ ] oh you can jump
wow what an incredible master of jumping
we need a box
hello mr. box you're my best friend okay
never mind then Jesus don't mind me it's
my box and I can tell whatever I want
with it hey hey what you goin do huh
what you gonna do huh oh [ __ ]
crazy works every time
we're gonna jump up here we're gonna
jump up here we're gonna jump up here
and here and yeah and then we're gonna
place box oh god damn it
alright we're fine fine nevermind you
know what they say
any man with a mustache has a mustache
hey stop throwing things I'm innocent
[Music]
did you two matter my face
come on mean I'm just trying to break
into your house how my drop box right
click ok and then pick up with Dee right
click drop ok ok have you ever been a
box
I hear that son of a [ __ ] dude I'm just
boxing it up dude I'm just boxing it up
I'm just I'm just boxing it up
I don't understand your attitude hey hey
hey hey hey hey come get me hey hey come
a little closer come a little closer
come a little closer milk there it is a
redish box it up buddy there it is
look at No you wiggle alone and you fly
off to space maybe not have gravity in
the 90s thank you
finally I get it Power Move Oh spa dance
oh oh I need something to break his
windows with right ok so far we have
nothing that you can really break stuff
with to be honest no bench could be
useful but I suppose not about a book
why don't we have a mustache thing this
that's got a that's got a smashed inside
all right can we break windows yes
absolutely
you can't break windows ok oh god I'm so
me Masi alright he threw the milk dude
I'm sorry about breaking your window but
it wasn't me no of course of course if
we can break the window yes I'm a genius
I must be the smartest player in the
whole world I bet none other thought of
this before I did look at this 3 360
that a whoa high-five there that was
sick man all right now we're gonna break
his [ __ ] window
it's fine it's fine I got time or
barricade or barricade it's barricaded
its barricaded what is happening
we're barricading we're better Kenny
what is this I think I did something
what is HAP Oh what is that he just saw
a chair at me what are you doing buddy
all right well we did that now so maybe
now we can go in here is that a [ __ ]
bowling ball hey catch he caught it
I'm so confusion oh there's a flashlight
we need that okay oh wow their window
repaired itself fantastic there we go
fixed it what how did this happen
fantastic everybody oh look at that
we did it that does not look like a door
thing okay oh there's another key keys
are good I think I know where this goes
oh look it's a magnet ah ah okay we have
the magnet let's not oh my god I don't
understand what this guy is and what his
issue is I'm just trying to be a law law
about thank god he's sleeping dude thank
God dude oh my god I'm just trying to
stack boxes on top of each other and I
don't think too much to ask I really
really don't think that's too much -
magnet time
it doesn't work oh okay well that's a
crowbar what about this oh wow what is
that lockpick in a crowbar we need to we
need to get rid of something or should
we get rid of the car keys we probably
don't need okay all right cool
now can beat him to death all right
we're sneaking we're sneaking I don't
know what I'm doing there we go
Vronsky runchy mine flagon thank you
hey a shovel Wow I love shovels ran ran
ran ran ran yes and now of course oh oh
what the what dude what what this is
crazy
Ricky Ricky Ricky Ricky Ricky all right
we need to drop something how about
yellow key I don't even stupid yellow
key red key right k oh yeah oh I know
where we are we're in the Attic dude all
right can I just jump out the window
then that works oh wow what just
happened so far everything has gone
super smooth I think we're gonna have to
distract them properly this time
because I think the red key goes to his
living room
oh here we go here we go did we do it
we direct that she's good - she's good
yeah very good
high five did I mean women whatever you
are you know do your thing dude we're in
the basement there's people here there's
bound to be people here hey put it that
noise I have a water kennel and I'm not
afraid to use it
okay all right I see what's happening
here we're gonna have to climb up we're
gonna have to climb but upon this one I
see you do there's something behind
maybe we need to start the washing
machine it's a sacred it's a second oh
my god Timmy Timmy lived here look at
his nipples Timmy are you all right yes
in your Tammy what just happened to us
ah Timmy nah so many secrets gotcha but
where is it nice and oh my god it's a
sacred pilgrim where's my flashlight I
needed it now I needed it now what the
hell is this pray someone's been playing
too much prayer
[Music]
maybe I shouldn't be playing this hahaha
I wish I had the flashlight spooky
spooky hey I can bring him you come with
me mr. Demi but I don't run to purge
master perk it up buddy
you're not a judge me O God daily oh my
what motion Daru run dummy
oh no dummy you're back I was just
chilling goddamnit
[Music]
hey it's me
[Laughter]
so that's the exit
can I go I gotta initiate the power in
the beginning okay
did he turn the power on oh he did so
then I just have to exit now
god [ __ ] damnit oh wait it's good
it's good yes yes ah yep oh no run come
on dummy we're gonna get away
what the hell dummy you can't do it
without me you have to goddamn it get
the what the [ __ ] did I can't find fine
fine fine you can have the dummy throw
what is happening dummy where I am I
just have the broom I'm sorry Tommy
that was sexual okay so that was the end
of Act one pretty pretty cool also very
glitchy a kind of a mess but let me know
if you want more flavor like as we
always say on this channel and remember
be good to each other and as always
squad fam